alors comment se décrit la chanteuse
Angèle je vous propose un tableau et
vous allez répondre tranquillement un
par un alors vous voyez ce qui est
marqué derrière non binaire non j'en ai
pansexuel ou hétérosexuel qui a une idée
j'ai Francesca bah pansexuel Jennifer
comme la chanteuse non je sais pas
pourquoi ça te gênerait non j'adore
Jennifer
ma réponse parce que pansexuelle c'est
quand on aime quelqu'un peu importe son
genre que ce soit un homme ou une femme
ou une femme
la petite la petite nuance avec avec
bisexuelle parce que bisexuelle c'est
qu'elle est déjà c'est que là on aime
aussi les personnes qui ont été en
transition qui ont changé de sexe
de perspective quand même ah d'accord
voilà
[Rires]
je suis pas mais pas
tu es sûr qu'elle est pas pomme c'est
pas avant le mariage c'est ça et epan
c'est pas bon non plus
j'ai l'impression d'être à Noël ça vient
du dieu Pan voilà le pan la flûte de Pan
et le dieu pend était amoureux et d'une
femme et d'un homme c'est la mythologie
on sait jamais si elle dit la vérité
[Rires]
elle a raison
elle a raison regardez ce cas répondu
tout de même en gel on va lui donner la
parole puisque c'est elle qui l'a dit
oui je subis et je dirais même que je
suis pansexuelle je peux tomber
amoureuse d'un garçon ou d'une fille
d'une personne non-binaire transgen
c'était lors des Rencontres du Papotin
vous savez on s'est rencontrées
exceptionnel où il se dit beaucoup de
choses mais vous savez que la pauvre en
gel qui ne voulait pas vraiment faire
son coming out c'est en 2019 elle a été
contrainte de le faire tu te révélation
d'un journal people avec Marie papillon
donc ça c'est pas bien qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de ça
alors Michel mais non mais c'est pas oui
parce que apparemment j'aime le doigt
donc c'est pas bien du tout c'est pas
une personne de choisir par rapport à de
choisir de le dire ou pas en fonction de
son entourage etc etc c'est pas à nous
de décider à quel moment une personne
doit sortir du bois c'est honteux
sur le moment ça a déjà dur parce que
c'est sa décision à elle mais après ça a
dû la soulager parce que avoir ce tel
secret envers ses parents ne pas lui
montrer son vrai Soi alors oui c'est dur
mais maintenant je suis sûr que ça l'a
ouvert pleinement c'est qu'elle est très
haut parce que c'est aussi important
est-ce que c'est aussi important de dire
ce qu'on est c'est quand même une
question très personnelle ça ne regarde
que soit et demande aux héros je trouve
que c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
demande quelqu'un tu aimes bah non maman
a raison on n'est pas obligé de décrire
sa propre sexualité on n'est pas obligé
de dire moi j'aime les plus jeunes ou
j'aime les plus âgées ou j'aime les
hommes comme si jamais
alors Isabelle alors attends attendez
attendez là on a raté un épisode alors
excusez-moi excusez-moi
alors Mesdames Messieurs nous ne sommes
pas responsables des propos d'Isabelle
morinium de temps en temps se réveille
moi j'ai été choqué
on demande jamais à un hétéro quelle
position il préfère c'est de la mettre
pris en levrette
Jean-Michel les Jean-Michel ont gagné à
côté d'elle pour que tu la surveilles
je me sens quelquefois dépassé par tous
ces commentaires alors finalement vous
avez une surprise le plus sage c'est
quand elle est où oui oui
alors du coup comment ça se passe